Nicole Kidman was a toast of the Cannes
Film Festival receiving a 70th
anniversary special fry strike they had
to leave before she could accept the
award because I swear the Oscar winner
never slows down but she did sit down
for a new interview and which she shares
all about her family with Keith Urban
and what she just can't leave home
without had twenty books on the go at
all time like I've read paper books I go
to the bookstore and I buy them
Nicole turns fifty next month and is
planning to spend it with her husband
Keith and their two girls looking
flawless on the cover of InStyle did she
give the magazine a hint about a follow
up to big little lies I just reread I'm
truly madly guilty truly madly guilty is
the latest bestseller by author LeAnn
Moriarty who also wrote big little lies
it's a whole new story with different
characters both Nicola Reese Witherspoon
has said they'd love to work together
again will you do more TV because of
this um I would love to actually I've
really enjoyed the great thing about
this is that there was such fantastic
roles for five women but you know people
are watching it around the world also
which is really fun like I've got people
in Australia calling me I have people
emailing me and text me going what
happens next but she and Keith never
text each other
we're already instead more face time
yeah we affect all last weekend can
Nicole seem to tear up when Keith
whispered in her ear and these two just
might be Hollywood's most affectionate
couple to get to enjoy these uh these
events like you know on a date level at
least on someone yeah oh yeah good I
made together and can you believe that
Keith almost never asked Nicole out on a
date
I'll give him anyone who you thought was
just completely out of your league Gavin
you have it but I'm just saying imagine
that you've ever met anybody like that
that's that's where I was at
you